ding-ding-ding you see also that cuz it
doesn't just kick guess we're on the
couch it's a couch cast we're on our
couch welcome to our podcast we're
actually podcasting from our culture
though it's not something that's pretty
great I like it a lot
I'm having a great time welcome to Gus
ken
okay seventeen couch class guys is all
about being comfortable which is why
it's sponsored by me and oh let me get
it you can get your me Andy's going to
me Andy calm slash Jenna and Julian get
20% of your first order and get some of
the softest most comfortable most
wonderful underwear in the world me
Andy's actually just recently sponsored
our 24-hour live twitching and they're
amazing
so go check them out we're on the couch
you know yeah
well I mean I feel like we're on the
couch right now because we did not fully
recover from our 24-hour to extreme no
it was mostly you I have absolutely not
recovered you know yesterday felt like a
fake like it so it was like a snake
sense of recovery like I woke up no bail
I think I'm good yeah and then we went
out drinking positions birthday and I
was like no not okay nope not exhausted
not good so you've been under a rock or
you don't pay attention or twittering we
on Friday starting at 6:00 a.m. oh we
talked about it last podcast we yeah
starting Friday at 6:00 a.m. oh we're
live on twitch until Saturday exam honey
wasn't Friday wasn't for me I Jenna
popped in and out year there for a fair
bit of time but I was pretty much in
there aside from a couple potty breaks
and getting concluded I was there for 24
straight hours which was one of the most
wild experiences of my life was that as
hard as you thought it was going to be
it was just different than I thought it
was going to be like I knew gonna be
hard
yeah but my expectations for the 24 hour
stream were like
I thought I was just going to be semi
tired for 24 hours
yeah the way it was though is for 18
hours I was just I was golden yeah
you're a good hydrated I was eating I
was I was just cruising
I didn't feel any towards the cheek for
18 hours and then when 18 hours hit I
went nuts and I started to slowly lose
my mind till 24 the last like the last
four to six hours were incredibly
difficult like and I didn't think it was
going to just all of a sudden be
difficult so that's what it was I shot
that too Jeff Jay Cyrus Jason Josh and
gas were stopping by Chris for playing
with us like we had so many people
contributing I drew a girl named Ethan
Ethan played with us Aniela but it was
crazy like you played pub G for 24
straight out yeah I mean jazz windows
that's location laid out so couch guy do
so weird however you guys Gasca but like
after that 20 flower stream like Jason
and Jeff are your real friends and like
that takes a real friend yes I hear
especially like I think just like
big-time because you stayed all the way
until 6 a.m. and those are like your
hard hours you know like I came in and
like really fat with you and was with
you for your hard hours you know yeah
because you need somebody to like
entertain you and like make you laugh a
little and keep you going and just like
really he really pulled through for you
yeah at the end there you just want it
to be over like one and there was I
remember there was a point where there
was like three hours left and those
three hours just felt like so daunting
yeah three whole hours laugh because
you're just you have nothing left and
you and you you can't really focus on
the game like you can't take it tears
there's no way you're getting chicken at
that point you're just [ __ ] around
you're just dropping them weird places
and doing this and that and all I wanted
to do is just not stream anymore
yeah but I did I was like so happy to
also really want to shout out
our twitch contact Kevin who plays on
the front page for a better part of the
stream yes and everybody's a [ __ ] and
everyone that watched would you say it
was a success yeah if you accomplished
what you wanted to if I didn't know what
I wanted to accomplish aside from just
going about doing it yeah so I would say
it was absolutely success I think it
went better than I could have ever hoped
well now every stream that you do after
that is going to be so easy yeah even
you know what's crazy about the tour our
stream is I just realize how mental
streaming is yeah like some of it so
much of it is mental and the longest you
might had done up until last this Friday
was six hours right and you would hit
that at noon I have been at news that
was fine
lots of the crazy thing up until like 9
10 p.m. I was like so good I couldn't
believe how well I was doing for what
like an 18 hour stream yeah and Prince
also streamed 24 hours with you oh yeah
of course not a shout hello Josh awesome
modern print do you have any tips
because I know Jason only did his 24
hour periscope his tip to you was to
stay as hydrated as you can if you have
any tips for anyone that wanted to
stream for a long time yeah definitely
stay hydrated that's number one look you
had a little bit of caffeine there
really great coming under the hydration
and then although I felt like I need it
in totally the last in the last stretch
I needed caffeine but yeah for most of
it I was just like chugging water I
probably had 2 to 3 gallons so just
maybe a little too much but I was like
over hydrating to the point where I was
like taking pee breaks at least like
once an hour yeah because I just kept me
going like I felt great like and I
didn't I didn't eat for the first six
hours I like fasted
which helped a lot because that's a
person thing like yeah I don't know how
everyone like maybe you do well when you
have the breakfast Romania coyote I'm
frenzied and it in a fast a little bit
that helps me but yeah I mean just like
have a plan and have fun you definitely
need some help
I don't know how Jason did is 24-hour
pull up alone I mean you deserve him
during it right I remember I thought we
did maybe
yeah there's maybe I can my on Monday I
just know that for the last like six
hours granddad's went to sleep and he's
just like a lone losing his money but
anyways that's kind of why we're couch
casting we are not completely recovered
from that day because yesterday we woke
up I want to we went to bed at like 7:00
or so and then we woke up at 4 p.m. 8 9
10 11 12 1 2 3 4 there's like nine hours
of sleep but it was like the wrong 9
hours and you're also missing like eight
hours and then five hours later we're
drinking right because will we watch the
UFC fight oh we should talk about us
yeah lots of prayers go to Tonya pitcher
oh my god bless up the sacrificial goat
if she was a goat but I actually got
really emotional after the John Jay
Buhner fight because it just reminded me
how unfair life is it's really true and
also and I know Joe Rogan actually did
you see an apology yeah but he didn't he
felt terrible about interviewing Daniel
Cormier after he got knocked out because
he doesn't usually do that he doesn't it
only does he not is there's like two
there's two parts to it I think one is
like Joe has spoken out about that
before he's been very vocal about the
fact that he doesn't think after a
fighter gets knocked out and is
concussed shouldn't be interviewed he
can cut to that idea and I agree with
that completely
yeah the other part of it is a lot of
times the person holding the mic whether
it's Brian Stann or Joe Rogan or whoever
a lot of times and producers in the air
literally pressuring them to do it
because they're like we need this
interview except what you have to do go
in to do that so something like it's
really hard to know when it's that
person's decision and when it's but the
team the producer team decision he said
that it was his decision and it's just
one of the things with like in the heat
of the moment it's such an iconic site
that's so much leading up to Joe I think
where he was coming from was like I want
I want him to have his piece I wanna
give him an option to just say whatever
he needed he didn't really show them
that he was kind of going against what
like what he didn't like he was going
against like you know his rule of like
not being knocked out fighters and I
think he realized little too late I
could tell he was like super sorry
cannot beating himself up over and like
obviously he means no harm but it was
definitely like it was sad because he
was he doesn't remember you know when
you get knocked out like that you got
nyeh 10 times not remember any of it
you're like awake all the sudden
everyone's yelling in the crowd and
everyone's telling you that you lost you
don't know what happened and that's
gotten we were talking about that we
were watching I was like I cry I just
getting acrimony cried I would cry you
know like a hundred percent at that time
cuz look at as you've ever been
concocted you know emotional man getting
concussed is a weird experience I've
only been mildly come customer life and
it's from it was boxing like with gloves
on and it was so mild but I was so
surprised that like the washing over
just intense emotions right after and
that's just purely out of like not you
know I wasn't even doing anything
important if it was like a big event for
me and people were watching I mean I
couldn't imagine how much more amplify
that would have been but yeah it was
kind of heartbreaking to watch TV well I
think also so there's a possibility that
Joe Rogan decided to do that because
Daniel Cormier also is an announcer like
you know he's a little bit more if
there's a conflict of interest there Jim
saying yeah that is a weird kind of
dynamic ER the way like Karen Brian and
[ __ ] Michael paging they're all
choosing Dania carburetor women it's
like okay not you know the rest of the
fights are there at the desk with him
yeah what a call force which is up yeah
but I mean I dream to thousand percent
that it's probably not always a good
idea maybe they wanted to make an
exception for Daniel Cormier decencies
like part of the team you know that
announces it talks about Vice it makes
theories and predictions you know he's a
little different or you know maybe they
had asked him prior like if you if you
want would you really something you know
I mean yeah and I think also it like
again in the heat of that moment you
don't want to make the wrong decision so
you used to you're like let's just give
him a chance
yeah
and so it it turns out that was the
wrong decision and he he was you know
obviously I think when you're watching
that you see immediately Joe regretted
right as soon as he hears what they or
Daniel says he's like fashion about this
but what I was saying also before that
happen was I just I missed John Jones
I missed watching him play she's such a
special fighter I know but he's such a
garbage human it's such a good fight I
know but that hell is everything how
good he was at each other I'm all and
that that's why I got upset after the
fight was over because it's so special
to watch a truly gifted athlete in their
prime you know be good at what they do
and watching him reminds you of all of
that and then watching BC lose and being
really upset and you know how much it
meant to him and how hard he's been
working for so many years waiting like
it's just so frustrating thinking about
the pinnacle of DC's career is waiting
for this person to stop blowing lines of
coke and hitting pregnant women with his
car and [ __ ] like he has to wait for
that person to get their life together
to then lose you know they're not tough
it's just it's really frustrating and it
just after that fight when Daniel Crimea
was crying it just reminds me like how
unfair life is and that you know this
person with exceptional gifts that like
almost threw it all away can just decide
they want to clean up their act come
back and just wreck you it sucks you
know but it is truly spectacular to
watch Jon Jones fight it's just it like
it all I could say is that it just
reminds me how unfair life is you know I
just I haven't felt like what watching
him fight last night and do what he did
like I miss the feeling of just being so
eager to watch a UFC fight if they
happen anymore
last night scribe was one of the best
you have any kind of in a long long time
it was like you're talking about Rhonda
when you see someone who's so special in
their heyday and their hair did yes go
out there and do it it just blows your
mind every time always on doing sites
like
I've always felt that about him and so
damn cool TFI I hope I hope the two of
five pound division can figure it stick
out so we can get more opponents RAM but
it looks like you're just looking for
money types now and yeah that Brock
Lesnar call out was really I was like
all right dog you know it really low
nice a lot you know man when I still
watch you actually fight and like be
really good at that and now you're just
you just want a circus so circus players
level circus does pay money it was
frustrating yeah but then after that we
went hang out with Jason burns person
yeah Jason burgers do it and drink with
them Chavez oh by the way we had
pickleback shots has anyone had a pickle
back shot because they are incredible so
good I just want to go do sort of why
don't you explain what a pickle back is
pickle back is a whiskey shot followed
by a shot of pickle juice and we take
which sounds nasty you take the shot of
whiskey then immediately after you take
pickle juice so you're left with the
taste of pickle juice in the mouth and
it is it's so delicious it's so good
look the heat of the whiskey followed by
the saltiness and that oh so good well
so gas and I were in the kitchen and she
didn't want to take another whiskey shot
which I don't blame anybody like a
couple whiskey shots you're like that's
probably enough whiskey for sure so gabs
was like I wonder if you can do a pickle
back shot with other types of alcohol so
she
I watched gags she took a shot of vodka
like straight tito's be like unflavored
vodka and then drink pickle juice and
just looked at me with the saddest look
on her face like I wish I didn't do that
you like it doesn't work it doesn't work
it's a super quick vodka I think we can
all learn a lesson from Gabe's the
pickle backs are only really for waiting
tougher so you guys don't have to yeah
she did oh I know it was speaking about
vodka with pickle juice life is a
[ __ ] rough alcohol sometimes man I
gonna do a straight shot of vodka
generally I can't do it it's nasty like
too
much yeah I don't know how people do
that you drink like Tito's great other
times on the rocks of llama okay see
that what he does is good vodka oh yeah
but I like I need like some soda water
like Tonya in there something like I
can't just drink straight vodka yeah I
can't do with all vodka I just like
serve my pubes really good
Wow let's know are you excited for
throws tonight oh my god I completely
forgot it was done I still feel so out
of it it's so crazy the feeling it I
mean you do this all time you stay up
all the time
for a whole day idea but it's different
when you're not living yeah I mean
that's what people were watching the
stream they were like why is Jenna seem
so much more awake than everybody else a
because I wasn't physically playing the
video games for 24 hours like that in
and of itself is exhausting all along
with running the stream is physically
exhausting and mentally exhausting so I
wasn't living ever taking care of the
dogs I was making sure they got food it
was a second operation like I couldn't
do if you were here like you were out of
town I could not have done that
like the dog needed to get taken care of
the house needed whatever yeah couldn't
you know it was felt a little bit like
big brother yeah I was your showrunner
yeah yeah like I was just getting
watched for 24 hours and you helped
everything work right but so I didn't
have that taxing you know mental
physical aspect playing the video game
though but I also do stay up a lot you
know you do I have you're good at other
other than I am which is a testament to
your will
well I feel like it's a skill I don't I
wouldn't recommend it to anyone because
I do know that it's not good for you to
get no sleep it's terrible for you it
literally takes years off of your life
yeah but I feel like it's a skill that
you learn how to get good at you know I
mean like how many nights when you when
I post my videos on Thursday morning and
it's 5:00 in the morning people are like
go to bed
it's because I didn't I haven't gone to
bed yet you know what I mean but you
sort of like learn how to push past
tired without caffeine and
get things done very effective appears
to be a kid someday I'll be like really
good at the whole being exhausted thing
either
I mean knock on wood I know that's like
next-level [ __ ] tired I know that's
next level exhaustion or tired like that
yeah but well cuz we are also your body
is physically like super stressed
because it's a human life you're human
right yeah it's not like doing your
kindness or progress very um plate
because I'm binge watching something on
netbooks just like no you're your body's
in a state of like pure panic because
you're trying to keep another human
being alive but I do hope so solo yeah I
do hope that I will be okay okay you
will I think as a team we'll be really
good at that yeah but I mean I'm yes I'm
excited for you sir - sir I'm sorry
JaMychal
the first episode was really good we
shouldn't talk about it too much because
I don't watch it and or don't want any
spoilers okay so if you guys or any
spoilers maybe four we're going to
mention a couple things what are you
gonna mention well I was talking about
night with Josh because I he's a huge
that's okay is he really I didn't know
that I think I mean he wash it but he's
into it
yeah so we were talking about the moment
with Aria and the direwolf last episode
yeah
Metiria yeah era whatever her name is
she was a bad [ __ ] one soul examines
like the way that happened I was where I
thought I took away from that moment
that it wasn't that dire wolf put upon
like actually thinking about it more and
then talking to Josh like it was but
because I had taken such a different
path since she had last seen the devil
and the devil also did that has taken it
completed with hot aria you know it's
like it was sort of like a mutual
respect like an object yes we used to be
this one now we're our separate ways
sort of thing yeah and that was
interesting I also saw a theory out
there though it's like remember that
Simpsons episode when Bart or Milhouse
or somebody sells their shell
all to the devil and then the 7-eleven
doors don't open up anymore
like since she did all that many faced
God thing and she can become anybody
maybe the mirror like recognize that it
was her but was like you are not you
anymore ooh anymore you're different
you've gone down to hold it like Aria
when 2011 the doors would not open for
her I never watch these things regularly
so I don't know that reference me that's
funny about right he like he sold a soul
to the devil and then all the things
that he enjoyed about being a person
like didn't work for him anymore
why did he sell us all to the devil as
of some stupid episode where he is silly
well obviously it's the Simpsons it's
very silly yeah yeah I was I was an
interesting for me but oh you have a
meeting tonight
what's the meetings gonna happen John no
I Khaleesi
you're gonna meet [ __ ] what ah I wonder
what's going to happen well I mean
there's a bunch of theories floating
around that he is a Targaryen that Ned
Stark actually it was not a some bastard
child of some other woman that he's a
Targaryen and Ned Stark just like a
doctor him or whatever I forget that
theory no big deal it I just want to see
down make out you know I'm fan yeah I
know that would be such an epic OTP Tom
hey how many people are there in the
Seven Kingdoms do you know I don't know
what are you a couple million was like
Erica literally total population oh I
have no idea sounds like it's it's
probably less than like five million
which makes it less than the amount of
me and Isolde today Julian Julian Julian
whoever fall in know you're it which is
amazing because according to me and my
source being me as the expert I am at
being me that is more people in game of
Seven Kingdoms
okay thanks and this appears in two cuz
I love
you so much and let me just tell you
what that [ __ ] green where I get into
like the product which the micro model
fabric three times softer cotton
sustainably sourced materials and
amazing designs get yourself communities
I just want to say the team at neon DS
is one of the most supporting wonderful
Pleasant hard-working and internet
friendly teams I've ever come in contact
with
I took a meeting with me Andes which a
lot of which has to deal with logical
we're doing we're talking about a lot of
different things potentially
but when I came to them a week not even
a week like five days before the 24 hour
stream I said hey I just thought since
we're doing sort of watching if you guys
want to get in on it let me know and
they figured out something and turned it
around in no time and they were so happy
when I could give people under way I
could give away underwear it was just
such a great experience to have like
them step up so I just want you to know
that like we love all of our sponsors
but there's a special place in my heart
for the me and you certainly they they
really stick their neck out for us and
come through when we need them so with
that said guys you should forget about
boring black and white gray underwear me
Andes has all sorts of different
patterns colors and designs of these
limited edition patterns every month
which are always really really dope this
month patterns were designed by
legendary 80s clothing grand cross
colors the names live up to their bold
designs and bright colors like increased
duty see a gig and the og give to him
for yourself so it's funny I had a pair
it was the colors one and it had yellow
areas like pattern yellow green and
white and I was trying to show them off
on stream but because we agree on the
lines to outfit yeah background see how
the song 11 is invisible White's like
you thing right now you guys get 20% off
your first or when you go to me and
cotton sausage annejulien yeah check
them out thank you Andy thank you me
Andy oh boy
one look out I know I'm hot I'm getting
a little hot too
can I say one of my favorite moments
from your 24-hour live stream when you
were descending into complete madness
and someone had quoted the neck problem
English my study so then the chat just
[ __ ] die grow into will first Jeff
started it because Jeff said the rib is
my rib is my bagel this is making fun of
like how it's done that saying is like
England as I say today my crib is my
bagel and then the chat just turned it
into bread is my wet bread is my direct
as I shampoo so like there were a good
handful of people who stayed with us all
for our I think the chat was also
starting to lose their minds yeah we
were all just loopy deeply loopy I there
was many tweets altogether I was like
when you stay up for 24 hours you be
saying the same mindset as someone who
has a point 100 alcohol oh yeah you're
literally dropped is literally drunk
which is that more drug than you can be
driving legally on you believe that's
right when when I step in do videos and
stuff I would never ever ever drive you
always drive as well never done this but
you mostly always drive sometimes I
Drive yeah you so much um but you have a
greaser losing if you guys want to see
like a complete moment of just like you
got nothing left mentally go to the last
hour of our stream it's on Twitch the
whole thing's archived what the whole
thing's on up really yeah we're going to
put on you to - we probably can't watch
it because the audio gonna like cut out
is the music but which you can watch the
whole stream you watch all 24 hours and
18 second
that's [ __ ] nuts yeah how can they do
that to switch there they know what
they're doing is crazy what is my what
bread is my wet we turn on a custom game
with me Chris and Josh and we and then
we just started like driving motorcycles
around and going after Luke race and
changing up like it was just so [ __ ]
would you do a 24 hour livestream again
I feel like after that one I was like
Julian you should do this again but do
like 12 hours
I could kill 12 hours all right zero
problem like and that's the thing like I
think something I think doing 24 hours
first as what your big event stream is
really cool yeah I've done the hardest
thing right so
like you said every other treatment can
be easy but it's definitely in a pale in
comparison right I would have no problem
with the 12-hour stream I could even do
like a 15 or 16 hours stream I would
even do another 24 hour stream really is
Danny I would do it again that's it
you know if I felt like the timing was
right and maybe some we this time we you
know got a charity on board and we
donated you know yeah that's very random
but I would definitely do a 24-hour
again I think I learned a lot from that
first 24 hour stream like I learned a
lot in terms of well so I'm talking
about with Jason I watch a lot of doctor
disrespect which by the way we almost
got in the game with him we had contact
with my mom died when you said that oh
it's like bitching why you boy privily
said why are you like a mob new weird in
the store our scream and we're trying to
reach us during the tour our spaghetti
game the problem I need to nervous to
play with him well the problem is during
more when you're streaming you're
checking my doc couldn't like link up
but we want I want to eventually they'll
be amazing I'd be nervous about that I
watched a little play I'd be terrified
yeah but dr. another thing is I watched
him a lot I watched a lot of streamers a
lot and one thing that I've always liked
been impressed with is how well they
managed reading subjects donations while
also being entertaining and playing a
game well yeah and I you know they have
their routines with it'll go mutant self
during the game sometimes to shot people
out or they'll do an intermission
between games and this and that and I
felt like that's one thing that I
couldn't really prepare for and for this
toy version because I didn't really know
that what their response was going to be
when I knew we're gonna have front page
time I knew that there's any more people
to normal condition event the way I show
up for this thing and I also didn't know
the level of how many things are
connected and they was a lot it's like a
15 times the volume of our normal and I
feel like that's something I learned a
lot from like I got a lot better at
interacting with the comments but also
the subspace donation while also you
know streaming and gaming and it's hard
it's like an incredible use of
multitasking to run that type of stream
successfully yeah you know yeah but it's
a lot of multitask it's cool to know
that it's possible though you know I
[ __ ] die though when you said that
doctor disrespect wanted to play a game
a month oh my god y'all dad [ __ ]
knows we're alive he knows we exist or
one of his mods knows we exist maybe
maybe the way to get in a game with me
do another 24 hour stream uh would you
do a 24 hour stream with the sole
purpose of getting noticed by doctor
disrespect I would do another extreme
with the sole purpose of getting in a
game with her I would just do it to get
melded you know this was that are you
going stream and donate like $100 he'll
be like what I'm doing but uh LMSs J ah
same ideas ah
do you ever yell stretch do I ever yo
yeah I yell stretch all the time did you
know me all sorts like all the time I
think you feel stretched out stretch so
loud it's like terrifying us yells knees
yeah on Medad god you yell breeze you
yell sneeze you do Oh guys dog fight
should I believe what is awful she's
allowed to go bubble did she goes to the
baggage room we're good this is so nice
so when we're having a couch guest so
the dog starting rying to get into the
podcast they don't even know we're
podcasting their brains can't comprehend
with the cover I don't know what we're
doing they just think we're like laying
here into the plain Canadian Jesus
talking Julien called Marvel something
new and funny yesterday you called him
the negative magnet - and I'm the
positive because you were like Jenna's
sitting here Makassar she literally goes
alright guys I'm too hot moves them away
I'm like what are you going to move a
positive magnet away from its negative
counterpart like it's just going to
float back and
he just blows back her he's like
magnetized Agenor
yeah he's my little management he's so
this really is all so they call him
spare from him sir like he's super tame
and sweet would use with me and then
when he's away from media is like he's
feral its barrel its feral its eyes are
bloodshot its feral he's not feral sir
was not feral he's fair role in the
sweet little angel he sounds terrible to
me I could hear him from here I fell
asleep with my makeup on last night good
work thank you probably ever do that to
you yeah sometimes I do honey I know I
see I trust me I see the bed I have red
eyebrows yeah and I guess some of the
best just bigger willow root sorry
North funny I want to get um my own
pillow too so I want to get a satin one
so here it's better for your hair and
your skin but then it will match our
sheets I was gonna set room and you can
lay in one oh my god I want you to leave
okay we're sure you're welcome to the
jana podcast julian has been doing job
twitch.tv slash jenna you thank you so
much dad joke but you not I am funny I
was reading dad jokes on the stream when
we tell you were you were that was
helpful
they're afraid bad we I wish oh I
actually I can show you I want to say I
wish you could show you the room right
now but uh if you check out my blog that
comes out on Tuesday I show you the
whole set up at wave are extreme 24 and
it's kinda because we brought the couch
in there like our little couch and take
the entire couch green so that just the
back won't like the back wall to the
back you know chair of it because when
no one's sitting in it you could just
see a couch okay we have to make it
invisible but then more people wanted to
sit in the room we had room for two on
the couch it was kind of a perfect setup
that's pretty good I think it works out
really great yeah I mean that room still
like tight with all the equipment in the
big table and yeah it's enough like you
just J somewhere in there and Jason was
also gaining
so we had anything that would be in
there like one point gaps and Josh were
also in there like you can send a lot of
people in there around that set up but
you'll be a little squished and
uncomfortable but you can fit yeah oh
you should get a second TV set up and do
LAN parties LAN party we should do that
why don't we do that
out out I guess because we're doing some
revamping I'm sure we've mentioned it to
the podcast room containing a new table
we're gonna get new lights so once that
stuff has been done I think that'd be
cool to have two pcs because only left
even because they have the same thing
it's like a room with two different pcs
so you can do LAN parties
yeah cause one zero and parties how
long's your lamp I was not here when
party I think of Ryan Higa I think a
love plan parties will do it my favorite
was when they surprised some first
birthday with just the LAN party photos
yeah
it's like the best birthday gift ever a
LAN party surprise LAN party in this
seven right Mike's part was it my 29th
birthday
I think Julian was super upset because
he wanted to go like do stuff and you
know go out to dinner and all I wanted
was to play elder scrolls then you let
me and it was like the best birthday
present I know I'm all about like doing
the most and being extra on your
birthday all you want is just like like
not that I want the opposite of that I
want to do nothing well I think for four
years ago and now I've learned I know
how to mix I'm dead serious when I say I
want nothing and I want to do nothing
like that is my present I love it
nothing is the present nothing is like
present Franco is my land party ok now
we're starting to actually the money
right it's my wedding I work I feel like
it's going to take another look at least
over there - yeah like a day for us to
be valued we have to work out so yeah
but he's drunk and we have ha ha
I need to get some pub Jean tonight
because I already miss me yeah are you
like are you sick of the game how that
you playing that what's crazy is we only
got three chicken dinner so I
underperformed in pub G like winning
lines I wanted to do better
than I did because I feel like a lot of
my best games are hopping off stream
which I guess is normal but I asked her
like obviously the day after like
yesterday the first part of the day I
was like I can't think about that
gameboy think about streaming yeah but
after talking about it with Jason and
watching a little on the stream on
Twitch today I'm like [ __ ] already to
play again I want to get better I want
to keep playing that's crazy because I
feel like I could play elder scrolls for
24 hours straight and just want to wake
up and play it again and then yeah it
won't make me sick of it at all yeah oh
man alright why don't y'all play pubs
you guys so uh okay did you know that
there's an achievement and elder scrolls
called Master Angler where you just
catch fish really yeah so like you know
in your and your profile or whatever you
can put like master wizard or like
fighters guild Victor like maelstrom
arena champion like some achievement
that you've unlocked you can put so it
says under your character name and then
your Twitter bio where you put your
achievement yeah it's kind of like that
so I've walked around and like play with
bunch of people and every once in a
while you'll see someone that says
master angler and like one guy I'm in
his guild and I was like that is like
it's show legit it's show [ __ ] insane
I was like how long did it take you to
get that like unlock that he was like a
year and a half oh my god
fishing in a video game it's Julian am I
kidding it's so [ __ ] boring and it's
not like oh you caught a fish you
unlocked it you have to catch like rare
fish in every location in the game is
that stupid
I love 2017 it's so stupid it's
incredible I love it i love i love it is
it Master Angler there's a someone
tweeted at us during this room there's a
twitch Xbox cheaper for watching a
stream for eight hours I saw that so
they were tears like oh thanks for help
me unlock this achievement with all of
them when Julian does last-minute trips
and goes out of town all like it's
Christmas streaming or like snake or
somebody I'll usually watch them like on
the TV because it's like I don't know
since you guys are always streaming and
playing like makes me feel
like you're here like I'm not alone when
I'm watching somebody else stream you
know so I was watching Chris stream one
time and you were out of town and his on
the TV his head is just in the bottom
left corner so I taped a couple of
pieces of paper together and drew him a
body and then sent him a picture like Oh
Chris thanks for going over and hang it
out then I came all the way did you make
Chris a body because it's like I'm going
on the bottom or so funny so you know
just a pro tip if you're ever feeling
alone and someone's on your TV like
streaming and sitting just make them a
body yeah you know and it feels like
they're here Hockman anyway thank you
guys for hanging out that's another
podcast yeah this is really nice for me
on the couch and chill I can get a car
cast your super truck we hit a dead cat
like in a non-sexual platonic bed cast
well non-sexual not platonic who are
still together well I would just do a
sexual bed cup hello King my god we need
Jesus
I heard you use our pocket pocket use
regular use my negative neg yeah let us
know if you guys like the couch taps we
can obviously do it again
they challenged us to something a little
more chill we were on the internet for
24 hours straight lives but we wanted to
be here and talk to you guys so thanks
for hanging out if you guys in a week
hopefully you enjoy your week in Game of
Thrones and all the stuff and if you got
me or needs hopefully they're
comfortable and wonderful and also last
time your thoughts about the UFC
fighting John Jones and Tonya Avenger
Cris cyborg didn't die she got down to
145 because we all know she went to 135
she would die I feel like they invented
that way class just as she could never
do about it cyborg 45 yes 100 cyborg
child and she really is truly dominant
and it will be interesting to see if
other people decide to step up and I
would love to see Holly Holm fight at
145
I think there's a more appropriate
weight class for her you don't put
anyways let's don't you you thought
about UFC or the live stream or
anything else we talked about in the
stream in the comments and they love me
fishy any drugs this week we're going to
rest some more
hi guys hi
[Music]
[Music]